attention undermining whether the Russian authorities are considering the possibility of a Christmas or New Year truce and are ready to respond if such a proposal comes from Kyiv there are no proposals from anyone such a topic has not been on the agenda time is money in our case in our version it is life therefore in order not to disrupt the task it is necessary to exceed this standard, which will save the lives of those who are engaged in the assembly of the bridge and to let the column through so that it does not collide in one place, it moves in a direct direction, we can blow up bridges and railways and buildings there in general, that is, multi-storey, anything, that is, up to to live to the airfield for everything you need time, everything needs experience to do it quickly, that is, without As they say, a well-functioning mechanism is called which is a team, that is, it is impossible. All the guys say they know their job, so they do their job